so if you have any type of excuse me one
second oh man any problem with mucus in
your throat today we're going to talk
about how to get rid of it using salt
very very simple this is part of a
series of three different videos to
address this problem from different
angles so whether you have a sinus mucus
or mucus in the inner ear or coming from
your tonsils or up from the throat we're
going to get into it so I'm not sure if
you know this but salt is is really good
for anything bacterial fungal yeast and
mold even if you think about um how they
cure meat they add salt to actually raw
meat to stop any type of bacterial
growth and even when you make Sauer Crow
you have this bacteria that is
fermenting this cabbage but then when
they want to stop it they add salt to it
then it stabilizes this stage of making
sour crab I want to explain what salt
does to these microbes okay we take a
look at my little chart right here if we
put salt on either a bacteria a fungus
yeast or a mold the salt concentration
is a lot more outside than inside right
in inside you have water and water tends
to flow towards a concentrated salt
mixture so the water is going to move
out of the cell into the extra cellular
area right here turning this bacteria
into a shriveled
dehydrated dead particle so the salt
will kill bacteria fungus mold and yeast
through
dehydration another cool thing that the
salt will do is it'll thin mucus so a
lot of times people get this really
thick mucus it won't come out of their
bodies well you can use salt to loosen
it up how does it do that the same
mechanism it takes the water out of the
mucus it breaks wakes it up and it thins
the mucus so we have two things going on
we have the inhibiting of the microbial
growth and the killing of microbes and
we also have the thinning of the mucus
so this is really good for an infection
anywhere in your respiratory tract you
could have a postnasal sinus drip
situation that's leaking down into the
back part of the sinuses into the throat
you could also have a situation where
there's an ear infection and there's
mucus buildup through the esta tubes on
either side and that can end up in the
throat as well and so here you are
trying to get rid of the throat
infection but it keeps coming from the
ear so the source is the ear the effect
is the throat so you have to be able to
handle where it's originating from and
also if it's in the sinuses you have to
handle that as well so this mucus can be
originating from the sinus from the ear
or even from the tonsils which are
little uh immune glands in the back part
of the throat which can swell well up
especially in children and be a source
of infection but really the tonsils are
trying to fight off the infection and
protect any invading of the microbes
deeper into the body so it intends to
create defenses and it creates
inflammation and a lot of times you'll
end up with a sore throat on occasion
some of the mucus could be coming up
from the esophagus because you have
either acid reflux that's irritating the
esophagus or you could have some mucus
that's coming up from the lungs so
there's many different uh things that
you can do related to salt from very
expensive to very inexpensive so let's
start with the least expensive thing you
can do you can basically take a teaspoon
of sea salt now as far as the salt that
I recommend I don't recommend using
table salt because they have so many
additives in their anti-caking agents
and you really don't know the source of
where they got that refined product I
would highly recommend uh you find a
good rock salt something that has been
preserved uh that hasn't been exposed to
Plastics and pollution in our oceans a
lot of times people will use Himalayan
sea salt but I will mention if you're
going to use one of the therapies that
I'm going to recommend I think usually
when you buy one of these units which
I'm going to explain it comes with its
own rock salt and so in that case you
maybe you don't want to put Himalayan
sea salt because that does have a bit
more iron but certain units also just
use sodium chloride so let's say for
example you're not going to get those
units you're just going to use uh some
sea salt Himalayan sea salt is a really
good one what you're going to do is
you're going to take a a teaspoon of
this sea salt and dissolve it in a glass
of water and you're going to drink that
down just by drinking it down you're
going to expose everything in your mouth
and the throat area to this salt plus
the salt's going to go inside the body
and strengthens something called the
autonomic nervous system which
especially focuses in on this uh flight
or fight mechanism it it tends to
improve that so many people will get
results just from drinking some salt
water so you want to heat up the water
to a certain degree so you can dissolve
the salt in there so you have the option
of drinking it or using it as something
you can gargle with right so you just
you drink this salt water you gargle it
get the back of your throat all exposed
to this sea water and you're going to
start to improve your immune system
because it's going to kill up the
microbe and start loosening up this
mucus so saltwater gargles are great but
just remember when you gargle with this
make sure you dilute the salt in the
water you may want to also add a
teaspoon of apple cider vinegar I like
fairchild's because it's a little more
concentrated and it's more pure but
apple cider vinegar changes the ph and
it kills microbes as well so we're not
only going to dehydrate the microbes
thin the mucus but we can actually also
kill the microbes by adding this Alid of
vinegar which is acetic acid now I'm not
telling you to put this straight
concentrated acid into your body because
that's going to irritate it especially
if you have a sore throat you want to
dilute it like one teaspoon in a glass
of water to make it more diluted but
both salt and apple cider vinegar works
really good for an
antibacterial effect as well as an
anti-inflammatory effect the next thing
you have an option to do is get a nety
pot a nety pot is something called a
nasal Irrigation in which you're going
to pour some salt water up into your
sinuses through here and it's going to
come out the other side over the sink so
the reason I like that is that you're
using this diluted salt water and it's
very gentle to your sinuses you're not
using any chemicals and it seems to
really thin the mucus and you will
notice that you'll when you blow your
nose a lot of mucus will come out if you
have a post-nasal drip all year round
suspect a fungal infection or some type
of mold growing in your sinosis because
that would indicate it's not seasonal
and hopefully you're going to change
your diet and come off any sugar because
sugar feeds this mold and candida and
fungus you'd probably want to do like a
nasal irrigation NTI pot maybe every
other day until it's completely settled
down the problem with some people is
they get their sinuses scraped out and
they might get surgery and now they
damage this very delicate layer of skin
that has all these good bacteria to
protect you against path
so in another video I talked about using
a drop of diluted kimchi juice and a
little cotton swab to add that
microbiome into the sinuses to give you
relief there's some great uh data on
that now the next uh thing you can do is
use a humidifier which basically turns a
liquid into a vapor and so you would use
this while you're sleeping right you
turn it on you put your salt water in
there and you let it run all night long
so you can actually breathe this into
your body into your lungs and it can
help to um thin the mucus one more thing
I would recommend is to really bundle up
and get warm when you're in bed because
a lot of times these infections
especially if it's in the lower part of
the respiratory uh area or even the
higher part the upper respiratory um
that could be viral and so antibiotics
don't work and so you want to heat your
body up and generate more like a natural
fever so you want to bundle up get in
your bed stay warm and try to sweat so
you can cook these viruses with
temperature and so we're going to kill
them with dehydration kill them with an
acid kill them with heat and then the
next thing you can do is what's called
halotherapy which is a couple options
you can actually uh go somewhere and
they have these salt caves that you can
go in uh or there's H theapy machines
which basically are like a dry salt
machine that puts this dry salt out into
the air and they usually come with their
own type of salt which is purified
sodium chloride and I don't think they
use sea salts they may I'm not sure sure
but these Halo therapy machines are a
little bit more expensive so if you can
afford one they might be worth it now
let's say for example you do this and
it's just not working it could be the
source of your infection is coming from
an ear infection or some type of microbe
in the estation tubes which can get
really clogged up for that you have
several options you can just take a drop
of this seawat and put it about four
drops or five drops in each ear let it
go in there kind of Shake It Out and
what that will do it will create a
thinning of the mucus through here and
coill off those microbes you can also do
the same thing with diluted apple cider
vinegar not concentrated just a few like
maybe four or five drops of that diluted
apple cider vinegar in the water one
tpoon per glass and you would put that
in each year so you have different
options of things you can do based on
your feeling comfortable about it
there's something else you can do you
can add uh one drop of garlic oil in
each year that works really well it
kills the microb and allows this thing
to clear out and of course you also have
this acid reflux thing if that is the
problem uh you have to watch my video
Down Below on how to get rid of acid
reflex but you're going to know if you
have acid reflux because you're going to
have digestive issues you might have
heartburn you might feel it uh
indigestion down here typically this is
not going to be the issue it's mainly
going to be either coming from the
sinuses or even the tonsil so the
Garling will really help now on top of
all of this I would highly recommend you
take vitamin D there's a large amount of
data on the relationship between kids
that have enlarged tonsils and a vitamin
D
deficiency kids and adults that have
sinus allergies sinus mucus and low
vitamin D ear infections okay in people
with vitamin D deficiencies and so just
the fact that vitamin D receptors are in
every single cell in your body including
almost every single immune cell it makes
sense to take vitamin D and probably at
least 20,000 iuse one little extra
strategy that I would use instead of
taking regular doses of vitamin D for
something like this is I would just take
50,000 IUS of vitamin D once a week that
way you get this shotgun effect and uh
you can actually speed up the clearing
of this mucus now if you haven't seen
how to get rid of respiratory mucus with
salt you have to check that video out I
put it up right
here